thank you it appears Ukrainian leaders
clearly understood what President Trump
meant when he spoke with the Ukrainian
president by phone in July and asked for
a favor the favor was a Ukrainian
investigation into Trump's political
rivals at home the payoff an invitation
for president Volodymyr szalinski to
visit the White House and the evidence
one day before the call kurt volker the
former US special envoy to ukraine sends
a text message to zelinsky's aid heard
from White House woke her rights
assuming president Z convinces Trump he
will investigate get to the bottom of
what happened in 2016 we will nail down
date for visit to Washington then after
the call Ukrainian official Andre year
Mac tells us diplomats once we have a
date will call for a press briefing
announcing among other things bur yzma
and election meddling in investigations
bur yzma is the gas company linked to
the son of former US Vice President Joe
Biden the text messages released by
house investigators show US diplomats
and Trump's personal attorney Rudy
Giuliani continuing to pressure Ukraine
to draft a statement announcing an
investigation but none was released then
in late August the Ukrainians learn of
Trump's decision to withhold nearly 400
million dollars in US military
assistance the US ambassador to Ukraine
Bill Taylor appeared incredulous texting
I think it's crazy to withhold security
assistance for help with a political
campaign the response came from Gordon
Sunland a wealthy hotelier and Trump
donor who was appointed ambassador to
the EU I believe you are incorrect about
president Trump's intentions he writes
the president has been crystal clear no
quid pro quos of any kind that text
defending Trump came just as the US
media was catching wind of a
whistleblower report accusing Trump of
wrongdoing in his call with a Ukrainian
president that's what's launched the
impeachment inquiry now targeting the
resident Democrats heard from another
witness Friday the intelligence
community Inspector General who
investigated the whistleblower report we
have evidence of text messages between
State Department officials expressing
concern as early as May that Rudy
Giuliani had a Jew there was a Giuliani
Biden thing going on that had concerned
a State Department official we have
evidence that a State Department
official was concerned that there was a
linkage between security assistance and
as he described a domestic political
campaign Democrats are trying to build a
compelling case for impeachment not only
to convince the American public but also
Senate Republicans it would take a swell
of Republican defectors to remove Trump
from office and thus far there's only
been a trickle
HIDA Joe Castro al Jazeera Capitol Hill